let's go back to the beginning for a
second because we're gonna build on
these fundamentals think it back to
feedback to sine inverse just regular
sine inverse okay we really need to know
the regular sine inverse cos inverse
10 inverse grass fundamentally if we one
of them progress to what happens when we
modify them squeeze and stretch and
shift them in different ways okay so I
want to know this really well so I
wonder if you can remember with me
what does sine inverse look like what is
its range and what is its domain okay so
I will help you I'll give you a bit of a
nudge in the right direction by first
starting off with the graph so here is
my best shot at a nice you know one line
through sine inverse graph a couple of
things to remind you of remember how the
regular sine graph and cousin town the
regular sine graph has stationary points
here and here right so I take a back
turn obviously doesn't if sign has
stationary points that means that at
those stationary points that tangents
would be at a stationary point the
tangent would be horizontal do you agree
but these in the inverse trig function
so the tangents will not be horizontal
anymore they will be vertical so you
know you have this shape right if you
could place your ruler or pen right
beside here and you're like yep
thumbs up looks like a tangent okay some
of the graphs that I've seen around
you're starting to get a little bit uh a
little flimsy over there it looks like
you're not gonna have a tangent there
please be watchful for it okay now we've
got zero here how do you remember that
sine inverse is the one that goes up and
cause inverse is the one that goes down
there's lots of ways to remember this I
mean you just draw lots of lots of them
and hopefully that would get it into
your head but your sine inverse and then
the next second you draw of cos inverse
and if you're like me I got very
confused between the two of them so I
want you to duan remind you of something
which you may or may not have looked at
earlier which is before you looked at
inverse trig functions just generally
speaking we thought about inverse
functions right say for example e to the
X and its inverse which is its inverse
which is log X right like so or we
thought about functions like say this
part of x squared that restricted domain
and it's inverse which is the square
root of x okay now I want to call back
some of the language that we developed
way back in the beginning of calculus
okay both of these functions are what we
call through some language okay we these
are both monotonically increasing okay
what that means is what what happens
when someone is monotone it means they
are talking in the same way all the time
their voice no it goes up it never goes
down that's what monotone means right
monotonically increasing means it's
always going up in DX never turns around
x squared in this domain never turns
around okay so it's always going up can
you see what that means if you look at
the original function the original
function what does that mean about its
inverse well look at log X look at the
square root of x do you see that if your
original function is increasing
monotonically then your inverse is also
increasing do you see that you see how
yep I'm going up I'm slowing down but
I'm still going up and this guy's also
going up okay
which part of sign because we don't do
the whole thing which part of sign do we
convert into the inverse what's the
domain it's from negative pi to 2 pi on
to think about what the sine graph is
doing I'm just gonna hijack this think
about what the sine graph is doing in
that particular domain from negative pi
onto to pilot ooh it's um it's
increasing isn't it and so it stands to
reason that its inverse will also be
increasing make sense and the reverse is
also true
what about cos which part of the domain
do we take to turn into cos inverse
where do we start we start at zero and
then we go all the way to PI and in that
domain cos is decreasing you see that
it's gone down which is why it's inverse
is not that guy its inverse is
decreasing is that okay all right now I
need you to help you with the numbers
here you can use the graph to help you
write and we already saw that air to
this question what is the wrong color
what is the Ray
of this sine inverse graph how low how
high near give plan to do I include the
boundary yes I do that's why I have
filled circles why and then it goes all
the way up to higher - fantastic
what about the domain this is even
easier negative one all the way to one
are you okay with that right now we need
to get those facts in printed L to our
brains because they will then help us
when we get to this okay if this is what
we want to graph and not just the
regular version okay what we're going to
do is algebraically we're just going to
shuffle things around so that we can see
the range and the domain this might seem
a little backwards to you but I promise
it will make sense by the end of why I
do it this way
okay firstly C is 3 and this 2 right
I'll start with the 2 first does this
alter the shape horizontally or
vertically it's a stretch or a scale
which way is it it's horizontal how can
you tell it it's horizontal it's
attached to the X which is the
horizontal axis yes what at the 3 that
changes you that changes the range it
changes it vertically to make that a
little bit clearer I'm gonna put the 3
where it really belongs which is with
the vertical variables that okay so I'm
going to write it like this is that ok
now you see how I got range and domain
out of the Y and the X well this is sine
inverse just like that is so I can get
the range in the domain out of these
guys right but the difference is I don't
have Y between negative PI to in point 2
I've got Y on 3 that's what exists
between negative PI on 2 and PI on - ok
and in the same way I don't have X
between negative 1 and 1
I've got 2x so that's what I'm going to
write like so okay so the real range in
the real domain are simply y NX on their
own so you can see in this case all I
have to do to the whole inequality what
do I do I'm just going to multiply by 3
and that gives you
negative three PI on T all the way to
three pound - what about this one
what'll I do
/ - bingo okay now meaning you're going
to say I already knew that that's what
it was going to be I can draw this now
in fact I'm gonna hijack this graph over
here that's how cheap I am and I'm gonna
say it's exactly the same except it just
won't go as far right or will go further
so range is from negative three PI on
two to three PI a tooth the shape is
preserved and from here to here what are
those boundaries going to be what is the
domain tell me negative a half to a half
okay and you're done now many of you
will say I could have drawn that without
thinking about the domain and range in
this strange way let me give you two
reasons why I'm going to encourage you
to do this anyway number one frequently
you will get asked for the domain and
range anyway like you have to provide an
explicit answer there it's like part one
of the question okay that happens a lot
so you might as well get good at
calculating it secondly sometimes this
is really the only way to make sure you
don't get your yourself in a twist
literally because the domain and range
aren't nearly so obvious